plus il y aura des décisions du
gouvernement qui sont dans le sens où on
a pu apprendre moins en moins de droits
le plus aura de gens dans la rue c'est
sûr ça va revenir quoi qu'il arrive avec
le co vide comme on la crise a été gérée
tout ça là maintenant on a trouvé le
nouveau les nouveaux radars c'est les
masques on a des amendes à tout va pour
les masques ce nouveau moyen de se faire
des sous donc ça devient n'importe quoi
tant que n'aura pas une révolution aura
pas de changement là c'est trop gentil
encore vraiment que ça peut être un bon
coup et qu'on merde pour remettre tout
en place
sinon il y aura pas de changement je
suis pas je suis pas dans ce pas
d'accord trop avec les freins ce qui
continue à être un peu leader des gilets
jaunes qui déclare les manifestations il
ya différents il ya plein de
manifestations dans paris on n'arrive
même pas à se mettre d'accord sur une
seule un point rendez vous dès que le
gouvernement annonce un lieu interdit
tous les gens se rétracter vont dans des
trucs autorisée c'est bête mais au début
dé gilet jaune c'était pas ça on n'avait
pas peur de venir et et pas peut-être
d'affronter les forces de l'ordre parce
qu'elle ne répondait dès le début que
move n'est pas ce qu'on a c'est est
notre conviction il y en a perdu un peu
de femmes et j'espère que ça va revenir
[Musique]